yeah okay we carry feet zip it instantly
I know patience is the key put enough on
my ship for free this is t we carry we
might go make some friends good morning
team with Gary Vee April 28th Tuesday
hope everybody is doing super well with
the fans let's just get right into the
show hey there man this is cool meeting
you thank you
I'm excited how are you I'm quite well
where you where are you right now
I mean I was to them right now in my
studio in a city so safe and sound so I
prepared some questions for you so my
first question that came on into my mind
immediately is if you were a musician
what would be the first steps you would
do to reach your audience like from
scratch I would create a social media
plan on tic-tock Instagram YouTube
Twitter minimally most likely Facebook I
would upload music on a daily basis if I
had the ability to produce that much
music my fascination with musicians is
how much music they sit on the
insecurities of having it perfect or
that they think their subjective opinion
of their own music is the right one when
we've had a history of people telling us
that the song that they least liked on
their album became the breakout song
that changed their career so I would uh
I would produce content at scale telling
my story Who am I why is this my dad
loved the trumpet my grandma taught like
I would put out content of my origin
story I would put out content of other
musicians I liked I would put out
content of just taking a photo of me if
I was a writer I would like start a song
and like if I was three sentences in I
would take a photo of it and post it and
tell people I'm working on something
imagine having that post like John
Lennon
you know you know I would I would do
what I do like like if I was if I was a
musician I'd be one of the biggest
musicians in the world because I'm very
good at communication you know I'm a
businessman and I have this much
awareness and notoriety out of my
ability to be a good communicator and
storyteller on digital platforms if I
have the ammo of actual music you know
my my best keynotes can get a million
views my best songs would get a billion
views right most and that's what I love
about you because that I think you there
are two people that I just go to on
YouTube that's you and Casey nice that
and I was just wondering if you would
you know it's something that you keep
repeating within your videos and
sometimes I do have to admit immediately
that I lack in that specific area
because you know sometimes I feel like
it's having time for myself and like
social media can completely consume
that's good that doesn't bother me like
I actually genuinely don't worry about
how much people put out if they need
time to themselves I'm more worried
about two things one when they are ready
to put out are they insecure which is
why they're not putting things out or do
have they not put in the work to
understand the functions or how the
platforms work so is it insecurity or
lack of grit when you're ready that's
what I'm worried about not that you need
four days a week to not be on I'm like
great then tell me about the three days
you are on you know and you know and
with musicians my biggest issue is they
just sit on music you know like for me
different because some musicians for
instance in my case I work with Roc
Nation so I cannot be like oh you know
guys tomorrow I have like ten I thought
I was in the place where I became aware
of that and I would fulfill my album
requirements and and I would use hip-hop
culture and say look why are hip-hop
artists allowed to put out mixtapes
which is free music to build awareness I
want to put out a okay you know what I
mean let's look at so Jim
wet the way people win in music is the
easiest game of all time they have a
song that changes the course of their
career yeah like all of them all of them
the Beatles
Madonna like Jackson Prince what's up if
you're a legend
or if you're great you'll have more than
one song if you're not sometimes you're
a one-hit wonder but you still had a
pretty fun career but but I don't
understand how musicians don't
understand that they need to put out the
music they think that if the songs are
bad it could hurt them I know that
there's tons of songs even by the greats
that the world hasn't loved I don't
believe it will hurt you and me Jess and
I do say I agree with your point but I
believe that I mean I made I think
together like six projects since 2009
believe me if you're the first project
you'll be giggling you know when this
camera goes off you'll be like Iggy
because it's it's totally not what I am
today but I do believe that it was
necessary to have that journey to become
where you are or actually traveled the
journey you know for the things you'd
like to reach so I definitely agree with
you
so before you there we go because I know
you're a busy man I have one more
question if you could do everything from
scratch again your business is to the
entrepreneurships that you're doing and
you could take the knowledge you have
today what would be the first mentally
change he would give a cloud thank you I
would I would personally probably go on
one or two more vacations in my 20s
because I was to 100% so for me it would
be a little bit more balanced in my
personal life professionally nothing
different okay thank you guys thank you
so much
Dustin I'm seeing a lot of comments that
my my levels are down what's up can you
get me yeah I mean I can hear you but it
is really low can you just try it
no no no go like this or something like
this or something
do tell just do a test one two seven
nine four seven um I don't know why I
hear myself I don't know I hear myself
how about now
it's still pretty bad I think he's gonna
go he's gonna go for the earpods and
everyone that's scared everyone that's
King Kong just the audio I can't just
the audio I can't in your yard working
on it I'm working on it with that yeah
it's just not happening right not
happening right now how about now it's
still pretty quiet how about now
it's still quiet now it's a little
better it's about the same do you want
to just use a speaker or save the
speaker you were saying it's not really
good I think if this sound I think this
sounds better but I hear myself but I
hear myself I put me on without you on I
just want to hear what people say yo
what's up guys can you hear me like back
to them go normal voice what do you guys
hearing is it better echo
how about now great yes it's good all
right all right let's just go with this
sound then your pods I'll be right back
Dustin keep them keep them on
entertainment okay okay
yeah that server it's kind of pale
looking that's a chair that you see
right next to his name Gary's on you I
think that's why I was echoing because
it was probably my voice going back into
his computer so how about those Knicks I
don't watch any sports so I'm just
talking out of my ass
um I'm looking through the comments here
the echo is gone that's because I've
muted Gary
there's too many comments coming in I
can't read it all so yeah Oh anyone that
wants to know what we're using we're not
using OBS zoom and restream anymore this
is just strictly stream yard Caleb said
talk about the evolution of tea time
well that is true yeah we started doing
this as like just zoom and OBS and a
super scrappy and I didn't like the way
the quality was the video quality was
terrible so we had the situation
yeah I'm still here myself what about
now yeah I think that's better yeah yeah
awesome
it's rock and roll cool nope Bret what's
good Gary
pleasure big fan thank you sir
your motivator you motivate our whole
team and company so I appreciate all
that you do thank you sir so at first I
want to say for all my team that's
listening I want you to get out there
and fail as best you can
yeah the relationship with no and the
relationship with failing and
relationship with losing is the quickest
path to actual happiness well as long as
we fail and learn from it we're gonna
come out ahead that's been the goal of
our success
but for for you and for for anybody
listening I own a bunch of liquor brands
I don't know if you carry I don't if you
know them my past friends were ace of
spades or mondebello of course and then
I started a brand that we still own a
piece of called deuce a cognac well and
then bel-air that's our one of our newer
ones you know bel-air I know it
extremely well
and then why my break wine library
carries all three Thank You carry bamboo
I don't know I'm not sure if they do or
not this is it's the fastest-growing
premium room in the world today are you
we're about to take over the number1
position which is exciting but to me
it's a perfect time to ask you about
what you're doing differently now with
respect to social media you know and and
and kind of in the context of your world
so obviously you've done an incredible
job you know obviously the first two
brands with one of the biggest stars in
the world and I've seen what you've done
with the lair with different individuals
as well in in hip-hop and in culture and
in different areas I think I think the
same way you know I think you know
without knowing the details like
obviously I think that people that
understand how to build brand understand
how
build brand so it doesn't confuse me
that you're doing well across the board
because we all find you know people
think it's people think it's so simple I
don't think it's as simple as saying hey
jay-z let's do this thing and then it
works there's so many things that is odd
your head and your team's head to
actually make that work motivating
salespeople in the in the true in the
archaic three-tier system creating brand
for other segments that aren't affected
by jay-z or dj khaled or things of that
nature fabulous you know like there's so
much other work that needs to be get
done to build a sustainable brand I
think it's about arbitrage of where
attention is right so for example you
may be aware if you're watching this how
much I've been pushing wine texts
yesterday we had a single piece of
creative on the one tech side that that
is working on on Facebook that is
driving subscriptions at economics that
are sustainable unlike before meaning if
we have an average of eighty eight
dollars in value of a customer that
signs up for wine text that advertises
all tens of thousands of people on it
you know now that we can pay thirty two
dollars for a subscription that becomes
a real life business right so what am i
doing different couple things one when
you look at things like fashion OVA or
or other things that have happened in
you know mode of watch or things that
nature I think for your brand's there is
a much longer tail of micro influencers
of an ambassador program that I think
would really work well it's it's kind of
the scaled longtail version of what I
think you've done well in building these
brands without knowing the details but
knowing people associated with it too
I think there's an incredible
opportunity now that tick tock is oh is
gonna is allowing liquor brands from an
ad standpoint but from an organic
standpoint
tick tock has exploded in twenty one to
forty five year olds and I think your
brand's have a ton of permission to play
there obviously if you're not on top of
every little nuance it you know it could
feel a little uncomfortable to go in
there because it's kids and this is
alcohol but the reality is there's a
threshold when the percentage there's
unlimited kids on Instagram and Twitter
and other places well once it hits a
certain threshold so I think tic TOCs a
huge place to look at as well and then
honestly you know just getting a look at
you and like really you know look at
hoping this
the start of us getting to know each
other I think you yourself should
probably start putting out content where
people become you know empathy wines you
know half of that product is selling
based on people being fans of me as an
entrepreneur who happened to drink wine
I think as people become fans of you as
a marketer as a personality creams look
let alone the successes you have under
your belt and I'm sure there was a lot
of failures and successes along the way
to got you to this place I think as
people become more fascinated by you I
think there's probably an arbitrage of
saying oh I like this guy he helped me
through my journey whatever that may be
oh well why am i buying this rum I'm
gonna start buying his rum and I think
there's actually a big arbitrage there
and a big opportunity potentially for
you as well there may be in something
like podcast or vlog form look this is
simple it's whoever's a media company
wins you know Walter Cronkite won cuz
everybody in America watched him jay-z
wins cuz everybody watches him like it's
just attention it's the simplest game of
all time where's the where's the good
deal of attention why set up and pour
for free at a concert or a festival or a
thing because through the last 50 years
of alcohol marketing because it's
there's a tension there and there's
trial and if they think it's delicious
they start considering it and they buy
it I think I think the modern ways of
attention this is it I don't even I
don't you have to start here you can
worry about being a sponsor of Coachella
or rolling loud or you can worry about
t-shirts for you know sales people or
you can worry about that [ __ ] later but
if you're not a Dominator on the cell
phone on the mobile device in the 15
platforms that when they're a Dominator
a real YouTube strategy a real LinkedIn
strategy a real Twitter strategy
you're leaving enormous economic stable
from from my perspective in the way we
look at things in the world you know I
think we've got great brands and they've
all been built the same way having no
money and it's my money and sometimes
you know you're looking at it from the
perspective of well I gotta be different
I gotta stand out I can't compete with
the Diageo's or the preneur card force
liquor companies Oh so in this
environment now where basically you know
purchasing power is
so significantly people are scared as
well you know you know sorry to
interrupt
red light and let you finish your
thought purchasing powers interesting
right because ecommerce had its greatest
two weeks of all time because people got
their $1200 stimulus check and bought
America even during the Great Depression
when I was buying makeup or during the
Great Recession where tons of luxury
brands were built
you know don't ever underestimate that
we live in the most capitalistic
consumer centric you know society that
has ever been built so you know you know
knowing that you've got premium brands
and things that nature you know this is
yes it becomes a game of who's better
now sure they'll have to be better but
it's staggering to me how much
purchasing power there still is even
when forty [ __ ] five million people
are out of a job
yeah we're built on credit with it we're
not attached to the gold standard like
we have we have incredible economic
power even at our worst it's capacity go
ahead I think but in some ways the last
thing I want is someone with that $1,200
check to be buying my products me too
you know it scares the [ __ ] out of me
the problem is you can't stop these
[ __ ] sure I'm putting on content
every day save save save save yeah and
then there and then they're buying you
know six $60 Pinot Noirs from me online
text and I'm looking at it I'm like man
I hope that person has to $160 you know
like it's scary the Brett freeze looks
so good two dozen he may have froze no
this guy's so cool that he might be
doing like some sort of like meditation
trance on us right now
yeah he's like pretty epic all right
let's let's get the next person in and
then work on him and we let him finish
his daughter we'll have him come back in
yay what's good how much man how are you
I'm really well Chris right on right on
well hello from organ one of the best
capitals of the country I'm sure you
know that hey I appreciate your time
today
so my question a little just a little
bit of back context
I've had the actual privilege of failing
my way through life
so I was never super great in school and
so you can imagine like when I found you
like that was huge for me right
I've actually been fired from four jobs
and was recently fired not that long ago
which actually spurred me to start my
business so the two times that I had
like thrown myself into my career I have
been fired which is interesting to me
the other two times were because I was
young and stupid right so so I decided
to launch this business amidst all of
this coronavirus craziness because I
actually I worked with a really great
Google ads agency and I saw there was a
need out there and I much like you have
a ability to notice trends and I think
I'm really hedging on marketing and
audiences how we consume and the type of
content that we consume I think is going
to change pretty big after the corona
virus hits and and you know has come and
passed I already see it kind of evolving
so my question to you being that I am 31
and if I get a good clean shave I look
at this 22
hahaha so how do I get business owners
entrepreneurs to one
you know just hear me out but to also to
help them understand that hey look what
you're doing is a bad idea and so we
know that is males yeah yeah so first
and foremost the huge key for you is to
realize looking young is just another
pillar of you justifying to yourself why
why the person would say no it's really
understanding like that you should have
empathy for somebody that thinks you
look too young or as an experience like
you need to get a great relationship
with no you know like you know when
you're already thinking about the
thought of like do I look too young or
how do I get them to think of me
seriously and buy for me what what I'm
most zeroing in on is like hey Chris
don't worry about that like 93 percent
are gonna say no anyway you know like I
was I was I was very similar
- like you know until they the Russian
immigrant you know DNA started getting
into the eyes and the wrinkles but like
I looked quite young most of my youth
and you know I was also trying to sell
wine when I was 17 looking 11 and of
course everybody said know what I think
you need to figure out is don't even
start I don't want you to even be
thinking about the reason they're not
gonna take you serious I want you to
focus on the three people that say yes
for whatever reason out of the 150 you
ask and then crushing the [ __ ] out of
that and then becoming that becoming
your reputation ya know that that meant
that actually makes a lot of sense and I
guess I more specifically like I'm not
worried about people who say no I did
sales for 12 years so I'm just eating
garbage my logo actually that I created
for my business was community created I
had been basically in sales and
marketing but no logo design what why
why why why did you get fired from the
two jobs like realtalk like if we're
gonna really bring value on some real
[ __ ] like you don't even want to say
it out loud [ __ ] you know what I mean
yet what why do you have the first one I
think that I threw my heart and soul
into I think that one it was more of
distraction and I'm not saying focused
on the exact specific jobs that they
wanted me to do what you do you so this
is interesting to me because there's
something going on in my world right now
I'm dying to see if this is what you
meant so what was what kind of job was
that it was a it was Wells Fargo sorry
business baby noise so you had a remit
but you were so fired up and so high
energy were you leading into other
people's territories to show that you
could and that puts you in a per curiam
spot
Chris this is [ __ ] amazing I love you
right now because I'm gonna make a piece
of content right now that's gonna save a
lot of people from a lot of headaches
and really Helen you and I right now are
about to help a lot of people like me
and you said so I've been thinking a ton
about this Chris I see this all the time
I have seen over the last two decades a
ton of people get caught
in this and right now there's a couple
of scenarios I'm seeing and it's [ __ ]
killing me and I'm trying to fix it and
I'm like and I'm just I know I'm
babbling right now cuz I'm so happy
there are so many people that work at
jobs who who get their tasks who then
start trying to do other people's jobs
or insert themselves into other places
they don't belong and it is 100% based
on insecurity so the interesting thing
here too is I agree with you actually
totally 100% uh be it for a second and
then I want your next one because I want
to help people listen to me you're not
tricking anybody by trying to like jump
into other people's jobs and like you
think you're try you're showing somebody
yourself usually but somebody like look
at all these things I can do I'm so
capable
give me more it's such a tell it's like
poker when you're unable to stay in your
thing and you start meddling in other
people's stuff you're trying to make
yourself feel better that you're more
capable a lot of times than you are and
you're lacking self-awareness and then
you're exposing yourself and all the
under conversations are really gonna get
you fired because people can feel it and
there's chatter underneath and I see it
from a lot of people and people that
work at Boehner and people work at Wine
Library people work at other places and
I really like them and I feel devastated
and I and I'm gonna start going at it a
little bit more more Candice with them
because it is it is a very common thing
I'm seeing and what I want to tell
everybody and I see the reactions are on
fire what I want to tell everybody is
this is so important for the young
Chris's who went through it and the
others and the people I'm thinking right
now that I hope you're watching you're
not tricking anyone I feel like if the
people knew this is the moment like if
you knew that nobody's confused you're
not showing that you can do a lot of
stuff you're showing that you're
insecure and you're trying to
overcompensate for your deep insecurity
and that you're tricking no one no one's
confused and it's gonna lead to bad
firing or getting
or getting put into a box where you're
just in the corner this is a big deal in
our society it rears its head a ton it's
a it's I'm just like it's crazy the
comments haven't exploded this much
Chris in a long time
like this is a big one and like I love
you right now I you came into my life at
this exact second because it's on my
mind heavy and I and I needed somebody
like you that was honest and could own
it like when you sit when the most
important moment this video Chris was
when I delivered what I delivered and
you said you're right you're absolutely
right that was huge because then people
you know I'm sitting over here talking
about it you lived it that's important
for people Chris it's a big deal and
it's also why you were worried about
looking 22 Chris I'm telling you right
now bro the reason you failing through
life and the reason that I'm your
[ __ ] guy the reason I'm your [ __ ]
guy is because I was blessed with luck I
don't feel better than you I got lucky I
got lucky with DNA circumstance and
parenting to have ultimate self
confidence you've been unfortunate but
not crazy unfortunate cuz your youngest
[ __ ] we're about to fix it to not to
not and you need to so I jumped
immediately on the [ __ ] 22 year old
thing it's why as soon as you said the
other thing I'm like wait a minute this
my life that's court you get a little
last night I was laying about thinking
about it cuz I'm think about three or
four people I love it my company that
are in trouble because of this listen to
me bro you have to go deep as [ __ ] like
[ __ ] deep to the roots [ __ ] you can't
like cut the flower you gotta go in the
dirt and get you know you need to
realize that your mom or dad your DNA or
your circumstance created insecurity
you're worried what other people think
you're not confident enough to be happy
enough but you can be and should be what
you need to do is flip the switch like
it's practice it's like working out
right like I used to have like puny and
now at least I have a little bit of
muscle it was work I do work every day
you need to do work every day not on
some foofy-foofy [ __ ] like I'm good
enough which probably matters to it by
the way cuz I don't even wanna consider
that foofy but I want you to go intense
on this because I'm telling you right
now bro you [ __ ] switch that and
realize [ __ ] like my big thing
unconfident
says don't put anybody else on a
pedestal Chris don't put anybody else on
a pedestal don't put me on a pedestal
don't put anybody on a pedestal
why don't you realize everybody else has
massive shortcomings massive
shortcomings once you realize everybody
else has massive shortcomings now you
feel on their level not that you're
admiring something you don't have
because guess what I admire your hair
there's probably and if I knew you well
I would probably admire your compassion
your kindness your your humor whatever
else but like but like bro
you need to work every second I'm
building up your self-esteem at all
costs and it comes in two forms one
getting to the root of the cause
actually going into that therapy session
or by yourself and crying it out that
your mom [ __ ] it up that your brother
[ __ ] it up that your dad [ __ ] it up
that your you know like and then not
resenting them being empathetic to them
realizing their mom or dad [ __ ] them you
know you need to [ __ ] work on bro I'm
telling you right now I want you to be
happy so bad and I listened very
carefully
you've got to tells like in poker that I
know you're deeply insecure and I want
to fix the [ __ ] out of it well I'll get
working on him in I'm about it every day
you gotta earn that self-respect every
day are in the right to go to sleep no
I'm on it so but stick with me even the
way you said self-respect this is good
that's why I want to jam with you this
important bro you're gonna first I want
you're gonna benefit from it but a lot
of people are make it all insular make
your try to make your life about you
with you you know like earning somebody
else's respect is how you get in trouble
of trying to like do something you know
like [ __ ] that bro Chris listen to me
[ __ ] them I like that it will work it
doesn't mean you'd like I love people
the most I just am not willing to let
their opinions dictate my life Chris
they don't know you when the SEO comes
and they're like get out of here like be
pumped not sad and I mean this and I'll
tell you why they just don't know you
yeah it's it also keeps people grounded
you know why I have humility Chris
because they don't know me but mean
meaning like I'm not some dark evil Lord
but like like but like I can't take the
compliment huh like you got a you know
what I mean
yeah no I know exactly what you mean
like they don't know you they don't know
you're in an ounce what you do every
single day of every single minutes of
what does a compliment or criticism
actually mean whether or not it's true
ma'am are you living it or are you
starting it or it's starting to become
the subconscious becoming conscious like
where are you on your journey on this
cuz it matters to me
ya know I'm actually just now realizing
that it's a it's a problem I've actually
been working on myself for the last like
it's taken a while so for like last 3-4
years I started like really committing
to working on myself
and I actually told myself two years ago
I'm gonna be very very be someday and
here we are
so things take time and that's why I say
like I failed my way through life
meaning that like I'm really okay with
that failing aspect because ultimately
is is led me to where I'm at now clearly
I support internal problems that I need
to work on and it's not problems dude
it's honestly this is what's so fun
about it it's not really problems I have
I have to work on my candor I have to do
a much better job telling people to
their face they're not good at their job
and they have to go I suck at it
I've gone from 0 to 6 so I'm proud but
I'm not in 10 land people I'm so can
Duras on this I'm going right at you can
Duras but if you were my employee I
would dance like a little [ __ ]
ballerina I mean I'm telling you truth
that's not fun for me to say that on
stage and on tea with Gary B I am
uncomfortably can Duras but once
something becomes my family I struggle
because the love goes deeper and some
something over the hook of like feelings
like I go far enough of feelings where
it converts to the inability to be can
Duras and I've gotten way better I give
my brother credit AJ came into when we
start a veiner he was much better at
candor um life like just like back to
muscles like you know it wasn't working
because when I would fire somebody
they'd be shocked they're like a week
ago you told me I was the best person on
earth
[ __ ] you Gary and I was like [ __ ] you
know I thought I was doing a good thing
by saving the person a job for a year
but
now I'm a bad guy like you know you go
through it you go through it so don't
think it's a [ __ ] problem you were
built to be insecure you don't have to
stay insecure in perpetuity that's true
what you have to do is reframe life and
not value other people not value them
Amina do not put people on a pedestal
you can admire things but like I'm
telling you it once you realize we're
all on it we're just [ __ ] humans
we're on a level playing field all of a
sudden by not over admiring them you're
not beating yourself up for what you're
not good at true and it'll help me help
them at a more effective level because I
yeah and by the way even the thought of
helping them goes away because you don't
you not even thinking about helping them
as the crutch in the relationship crap
you see where I'm going yeah now that
makes sense that's your your way to when
you admire something what do you think
some veterans like okay I'm gonna help
them that's going to that's going like
that's gonna even us mm-hmm yeah yeah
yeah it brings you up right that's your
leverage hey let me help you they're
like they're not asking for help right
right yeah and I see this drug you are
like drilling everything for me I can't
believe you just said that I knew I
wanted to keep you on here like I'm
telling you you're you know buddy you're
you're helping a lot of people Chris
there's a lot of you Chris there's a lot
of Chris tuggers in the world sure I see
them all the time and you know what's
funny I love them I'll tell you why even
notice how earlier I said your
compassion your kindness yeah I could
feel it because I know you cuz I seen
you a lot and I see a lot of them in my
company I see them a lot of my friend
Graff you need to work on your
insecurities you're not tricking anyone
and I'm gonna help them is trying to
trick them into a level playing field
because you're so insecure of your
actual truth of your capability that's
posturing yeah yeah yeah yeah good news
not in a way it's a hundred percent
posturing and here's where really really
sucks you
Rick the people you don't care about and
you expose yourself to the people you do
care about ooh I got some work to do not
work opportunity brother this is good
you know I do I yeah let's go it's good
but you understand it's okay yeah like
it's like it's good yeah no I it is it
is you're right you're right and it's a
an insecurity and a posturing that I
didn't realize I was I was doing man the
reason I know you were doing it is as we
talked as I listened you know it's that
I'm gonna get into this person's lane
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna help that
person
these are cliche it was really
interesting as something just to be your
authentic self and I always thought that
that was my authentic self because I do
enjoy helping people so much I believe
that but but I do too and I don't seek
it out it comes to me that's the
difference yeah yeah you're he's coming
to me now so I'm starting to see it a
little bit so thank you for helping me
along with that because that's just
gonna help it come even me Chris listen
to me you're [ __ ] awesome dude I can
smell it and taste it through the
computer what you need to do is lead
with your shortcomings not try to
disguise them yes sir
might take a while but I'll be on it man
I'll be on it
I love you know what that was my
favorite thing you I don't know if you
see the goosebumps I hope I love you for
recognizing it's not gonna be one talk
with Gary B and tomorrow but listen to
me it's it's not as hard as you think
once you make that this is why I use
this word you're not tricking anyone
Chris there are people the people like
when you're doing your peacocking and
posturing you think it's working and
what's happening behind your back is the
conversations are not what you want them
to be that's true now you know the
reason for my hair it's the people
brother I'm proud of you like you should
get comfortable with this
yeah something you don't need to be
uncomfortable with you don't need to
like they hate like get comfortable
it's you you understand that's why this
is powerful you don't need to deflect
you don't need to convert it into the
hair as a peacock it's you you're
[ __ ] awesome
yeah yeah thank you yeah absolutely and
like I said it's gonna take a while for
me to work on it but it is gonna take a
while but the biggest thing I think I've
given you and I hope you can build on it
with somebody else is you're not
tricking anyone and good news this video
is gonna be watched by a million people
over the next three years so you're
definitely not gonna hide and that's the
best thing that happened to you not the
worst once you did once you once you and
the four or five seven people I love
that I'm thinking about right now my
companies and friends circles and
contemporaries realize how real this
[ __ ] talk was the whole world's
getting a better tricking anyone world
man we need more real so thanks for
helping me be even more real oh my [ __ ]
January it's a good thing man you know
why there's nothing to be embarrassed of
so what so you don't go into every
situation thinking you're gonna crush it
who gives a [ __ ] so you're not the
leader or the [ __ ] fixture that you
think you're who gives a [ __ ] you can be
if you get real with yourself and
realize you're not there yet and and
realize you can't talk your way or act
your way out of it you're gonna be seen
for your truth by the smartest emotional
people who are really running [ __ ]
anyway so where the [ __ ] are we going
round circles really at that point
correct that's why you're at where
you're at and what's awesome is your
[ __ ] child yeah your [ __ ] child
this Hulk the best part of this whole
conversation is literally everything
that's happened up to this second
doesn't mean [ __ ] like all that garbage
like that you're thinking about right
now good news there's no time machines
you can't go back anyway why don't we
focus on the next 71 years of your life
where you [ __ ] own this all the way
through and go [ __ ] ham on your
[ __ ] actual authentic self not the
authentic self that you're looking to
present so people don't actually know
the truth
going on yeah let's let's go yeah and
you know what I DM you all the time
anyway it's kind of like a cathartic
thing so I'll keep pace with you on this
area like I'm gonna work on this and do
me chop this chop this turn into audio
and listen to it it will help you man
here's why I want the reminder to know
every time you're doing something that
nobody's getting fooled ooh we're
getting uncomfortable okay I get it
though I know you man I could I sensed
you from it's like and you're and you're
thinning something that's really the
reason we're so deep on this one and I'm
going so deep and I appreciate you
sitting with me because it's not it is
uncomfortable and I respect you too you
you cannot imagine how much I admire you
with the strength to sit through this
Wow okay thank you seriously who the
[ __ ] wants to be on the spot being poked
that there's it like this
I admire you tremendously your feedback
I mean a lot and this is this is so
incredible that like I I'm just I'm here
from a position of learning so well I
think you really think you can pull this
off what you need for me is the reminder
that unless you go completely you it's
not gonna work that's true and so it's
gonna have short term you trick that
person you trick this person but like
somewhere along the line it's gonna get
exposed and depending on the emotional
intelligence of the person I [ __ ]
understand you in four seconds you can
say [ __ ] yeah cuz I'm on some Yoda [ __ ]
with my EQ right but but I have no
reading comprehension I don't feel like
I'm special it's just I feel like it was
what I was handed and then somebody else
who might not be emotionally intelligent
you might be able to trick them for a
year for two years but eventually it's
gonna happen
and so what I'd rather write you see
where I'm going yeah it goes across like
your whole life like the most authentic
person that I am like my most authentic
self is with my wife and that's like my
most successful relationship I love that
bro
you've completely won the love of
everybody this is your this is your
handle right here yeah it's actually all
24 hours old
I'm doing this all myself so and I
haven't really done any sort of like
design or anything like do it nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your design bro
nobody gives a [ __ ] about the design
stick with me no more valuing their
opinions you know how I think about
logos I don't give a [ __ ] poor Robbi
Deeks we announced Bainer Conners
yesterday he like got super sad like a
week ago when he when like the team
showed him the first logo and he's like
you approve this I'm like yeah he's like
this dog [ __ ] I'm like like who gives a
[ __ ] logos are made names are made your
logo is not the variable in your success
your Foom and shoe is not the variable
of your success you know don't let other
people's opinions have any weight be who
you are and go and execute like let let
the results speak not the people's
opinions upfront I prefer when people
think I can't pull [ __ ] off you know
Kristen I'm in a weird part of my life
where my level of success and notoriety
has now put me in a place where people
think I'll be successful and everything
I launch and I hate it
much fun do you know what tonight yeah
but guess what bro that's the reverse of
you like like I like underdog I like
people [ __ ] on me yeah i pot I pop I
would actually argue I'm the reverse of
you and I posture down one of the things
I don't like about tea with Gary Vee is
I'm getting a lot of emails of like hey
you're much smarter than I thought
hey you're more thoughtful than I
thought and like [ __ ] they're figuring
me out because I like them going crazy
I'm you know like I kind of like the
Rhodope of like not you know like
because I don't have tried in my
intellect I have pride in my humility
and giving back and that's where I want
me that's where I feel like I'm
operating it yeah bro but you can't be
you can't give until you're [ __ ] in a
good place and you're not in a good
place
yeah you're right your gosh your brother
your fake giving as a leverage point to
subsidize your insecurity and
inferiority but you don't have to be
this is the moment we can literally
listen you were [ __ ] right about
meeting me this is the moment I'm not
letting you go cuz I'm not done I'm
trying to [ __ ] change your life
forever there's one because one
conversation can do it
ah this is my boy Frankie but now this
means that I'm gonna have to do yes see
what I'm doing you is I'm giving you the
gift of suffocation yeah you know
everybody else around you has enabled
you to still play into the creases I'm
trying to smoke you the [ __ ] out because
smoking you the [ __ ] out is actually how
you start getting to happiness
I feel pretty smoked not gonna lie
sitting here right now my mouth is dry I
mean I can't even handle said I deployed
some real smoke you know like I get it I
brought my big smoke pack you know why
cuz I love you and I think this will
really work
hey man I love you to him for what you
do
and I this is incredible thank you I
mean Lana look truly the gratitude right
now is thank you I said brother last
parting shot recognize that this will be
watched over a million times so you're
not gonna be able to hide anyway so who
cares so let's it's over the shadow game
the manipulation game they're like
trying to find an angle so people don't
know game it's over it's actually really
nice it's the greatest gift of all it's
actually really really nice no no
brother it's the medicine that everybody
that's wired like you actually meets but
nobody wants to go there it's
uncomfortable it is of course it is and
it's easier when you're a little more
disconnected right the reason I struggle
with this candor with the people I love
is cuz I'm connected so I don't judge
your mom your wife your best friend cuz
I'm not capable of it either on that
intimate of a level of feelings but I'm
very capable of it maybe the best at it
when it comes to this because I can wing
people so fat I can read so fast and so
even within this 16 minutes I can get it
off yeah yeah I know that makes a lot of
sense well today's my content creation
day so every once you actually hear me
out every day is gonna be your content
creation day because once you go into
confidence you're always creating
because you're not worried about the
results on the other side of the
creation
why am i able to produce so much content
cuz I don't give a [ __ ] when a piece of
content doesn't succeed I don't think
twice when something doesn't perform I
don't stop when somebody says I'm full
of [ __ ] or I suck you got it yeah I
totally get I have a ton of fun creating
content you just don't know you just
don't like you're just not you're just
insecure with the feedback you're
totally right yeah 100 yeah yeah I know
you and I love you the you the most I
know you and out of all the people that
run in the different groups of 55
different kind of things 100 it's you
who I love the most because there's a
kindness and an insecurity that creates
this really interesting personality
trait that I can see from this screen
with you and I have a lot of love for
you and I really want you to win and
this is the singular conversation that
I've seen over my years of life that
actually helps that person yeah I'm
Florida I don't even have anything left
to say you're alright brother
just go and do it go with your DMS a lot
of these people are hitting you up this
is a really kind community this might be
the virtual community that helps you
prop up but do me a favor Chris watch
this over and over and just if you
remember anything you're not tricking
anyone and not anyone you want to be
tricking do you know what I mean you
gotta change up your whole script you
know the you've just you know you're
just not you're not pulling it off do
you know what I mean yeah I know what
you mean cuz I'm here where I'm at and
we're talking right now so clearly I'm
not and it's bringing true to me so yeah
that's the truth that's how you figure
out it's the truth right and like the
common thing with guys and gals like you
is they fool the least emotionally
intelligent and so that's they think
they're pulling it off but what they're
losing with is the most emotionally
intelligent and emotional intelligence
is the Alpha of our society and so you
need to really understand that yeah yeah
and by the way you just you know you
didn't it didn't work in a work
environment because eventually
somebody's boss or boss or your direct
boss understands that so that's not
gonna work and it's not gonna work with
your business because you're not gonna
customers they see right through it and
the customers you're gonna get are gonna
be the least emotionally intelligent
which is gonna be sucky customers and
then the whole thing is gonna break or
you listen to this over and over every
day the rest of your life until you
don't need me no more and you [ __ ]
are the reverse version which is you're
comfortable with losing you're
comfortable you know with not succeeding
you don't worry about the judgment
anymore even though you grew up in an
environment where the judgment over was
overvalued you start chipping away at
that and creating a new version of
yourself and you can because really have
no choice you have no choice cuz you
know I'm right and you have no choice
because a million people gonna watch
this and you're not gonna be behind in
society sure it's a hundred percent true
so yeah I just got I've got to get to
work and I'll hammer on this I believe
you that's why I'm sticking here so long
i weirdly believe you update meaning
your brother I love you definitely look
back Gary thank you so much man
that was good we have Brett in door
number one that's back or would you like
to go at this lovely couple Jason and
Tilly in door number two I'm going to uh
I'm gonna wrap up we're gonna get them
on for tomorrow okay I've only got eight
minutes and you know it's kind of like
you ever see like and there's like
superhero movies where like the port of
you know all the sci-fi stuff like the
person gives all the energy but then
they're like like this is like this is
like the episode where like I you know
just yeah I'm just gonna wrap up okay I
appreciate it but I'm sorry to cut it
short but I left it all in the field on
that one
so I hope you have a wonderful day
please let me know if you got value out
of that last session please please hit
me up on Twitter I've got a few minutes
before my next thing I could really use
the comments use my Twitter a lot of you
don't hit me up on Twitter please hit me
up on Twitter I'd really I'd really like
to talk to you about that I'd like to
see how many people yeah thank you for
watching I'll see you tomorrow I am
giving away the ultimate garyvee
experience how should I go okay over the
last week or so I've been a gym with my
friend Michael Rubin and helping out on
this all-in challenge that I am
accepting right now but all-in challenge
calm please go there we are challenging
some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction so my auction
the ultimate Gary the experience here we
go I'm gonna go off the top of the head
I didn't go on all-in challenge calm to
go bid on this I am giving away okay you
get to in the course of the year you
will go garage sailing with me and film
trash talk also you can get a workout
with me and Mike pecan tea so I know a
lot of you pay attention to that part of
my world also we're gonna go to Wine
Library and do a $25,000
shopping spree that's right I'm gonna
pay my dad well I'm gonna donate we're
gonna pay my dad 25 thousand so $25,000
shopping spree at Wine Library I will
walk through the whole store with you
tell you the war stories and you'll buy
a bunch of a wine beer liquor whatever
you want food we are going to go to a
Jets game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play at Vayner
media so this is for you and a plus-one
by the way so the two tickets the will
be some plus ones we'll do some just me
and you depending on this one full week
at vaynermedia getting consulting and
business advice from team Gary Vee and
me for the entire week hanging out in
the pit where the shows done you're
gonna be a guest of my podcast we're
going to do a wine dinner for you and
seven of your friends at Hunt fish club
in New York City and I'm gonna fly you
all paid plus 1 2 3 of my keynotes and
we'll work on those details the ultimate
garyvee experience I hope you bid on it
I hope you get involved I hope we raise
a lot of money to help people that need
it all so what's so fun about the Olin
challenge is you get to challenge people
to be in it I am gonna challenge all the
Boehner sports athletes I expect you in
there so that is number one number two
I'm gonna go with ooh you know what Tim
Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Timbaland the super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge comm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all and challenge please check
it out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hashtag all and challenge to
get them involved they all and challenge
please take it